President Trump today and President
Trump in the last school shooting where
he was referring to what they were going
to do moving forward again this school
shooting in Santa Fe Texas comes as you
take a look at the mass shootings this
year so far this list includes three or
more victims killed not conventionally
motivated crimes or killings in private
homes but you now have Santa Fe Texas
ten killed here we heard from the White
House today that the education secretary
Betsy DeVos has her school safety
commission has been stood stood up today
and that it will meet for the first time
next week what about this we'll start
there on the day's events let's bring in
our panel Matt slap contributor with the
hill david cantonese senior politics
writer for US News and World Report and
noah rothman associate editor of
commentary magazine no let me start with
you you know where we're going and where
the conversation goes would come to this
point every time there's a shooting
especially a school shooting yeah they
have become so common at this point so
tragically common that our response is
almost ritualized conservatives respond
by talking about conservative issues
Democrats respond by addressing guns
this doesn't look like a weapons issue
we saw Senator Chris Murphy say that we
need to talk about weapons the
perpetrator apparently from what we know
had a sawed-off shotgun which is illegal
and a revolver which no one is talking
about regulating we don't know how they
were stored but at this point I think
it's pretty safe to say that we have a
copycat issue here that then that's a
media issue there's enough scholarly
scholarly literature to suggest that
young students are seeking to emulate
the horrible legacies of people like the
Columbine shooters which is evident in
this shooter who was wearing a trench
coat and we need to really talk about
press coverage in that point and that's
something that I don't think anybody
really knows how to address yeah David
look I mean you played the clip spread
three months ago President Trump
basically said the identical same thing
as he said today and it's probably sad
to say but in three to four months now
we'll probably be in the same situation
you had the
lieutenant governor of Texas suggest
today I heard that the problem was the
amount of doors in the school that it
had nothing to do with guns but that it
had to do with entry points and if there
are fewer entry points into the school
the shooter could be stopped so there's
no agreement on this issue between
Republicans and Democrats and I don't
think we will see any agreement until
you have a change and upheaval and power
in Washington Matt yeah to me it's time
to get practical and to think about the
basic steps we could take you know I
drop off four of my kids at school every
morning in a off-duty police officer
brings the cars in for the drop-off but
then leaves when school starts and I
think there are too many schools that
are vulnerable to attack and we have
these big constitutional questions
questions about violence in our society
I don't know if these are going to get
resolved politically but I know one
thing we can do is we can harden these
schools we can protect our kids we can
get real that with the fact that there
is violence in our society and it's a
terrible terrible thing when we do
nothing to stop it all right let's move
to another topic and that is the
investigation the Russia probe led by
Special Counsel Muller Rudy Giuliani the
president's attorney now has been out
talking to a number of different
networks here at Fox and others here he
is talking about that the president how
he would testify the president is not
gonna lie let's get that straight
president is gonna tell what gives you
confidence to secret I've gone over the
whole thing I've investigated the whole
thing there's nothing a lie about all
right so the question is no are they
setting up potentially to have the
president talked to Robert Muller well
it sounds like that apparently there's
some effort ongoing mr. Giuliani spoke
with Fox News and said that there's some
preparation almost debate prep there
going to be were returning to the area
in Bedminster New Jersey where they did
some debate prep in 2016 and they're
gonna walk the president through these
talks and there's negotiations about
what they're going to speak to so yes
apparently the president is going to be
deposed by the council which is a
fraught prospect but I don't think the
president could have ever avoided it
meantime David we're waiting for this
inspector general report
and there's all kinds of reports
including the New York Times about the
FBI using informants inside the Trump
campaign at the early stages of that
Russian investigation there are reports
about that but we don't know exactly who
the informant is the accuracy of this
report what what the informants goal was
if there was an actual informant so you
know a lot of questions remain around
that on the Moller investigation they
were referring to read Giuliani his
comments I think the most significant
thing that came out of his mouth this
week is that Muller seems to say that he
will not indict the president that he
doesn't believe he can indict President
Trump so I think the next key thing to
watch and this Muller investigation is
who is in his sights
is it a member of the president's family
could they be charged could it be Jared
Kushner could it be Donald Trump jr. or
are all the fish already fried are all
the charges that we know of is that
basically going to be it I think that is
the the main next question I'm watching
the smaller investigation Matt and the
investigation into the investigation is
also one to watch yeah absolutely look I
think the problem for Robert Muller is
is that his if you look at his poll
numbers they've been coming down and
been coming down and it looks like the
lawyers he hired really have a political
axe to grind against Donald Trump so I
actually think politically for the first
time I don't think there's a downside to
the president avoiding this conversation
with the special counsels team and I
think the second thing is with knowing
and seeing James clapper on CNN talking
about how it was a good thing to have a
spy in the Trump campaign is the most
audacious thing I think I've heard of
and I actually think we needed to our
commission much like Ronald Reagan did
pick three people of eminent reputation
who understand the national security
threats to using the national security
and intelligence community apparatus to
spy on our political opponents I think
these are very big questions we owe the
American people some real answers and we
gotta have some safeguards